i'm ryan right he's Jerry listen up it's
reasons to see it's three o'clock in the
morning because it's daylight savings
guess what we just shot Wonder Woman and
we stumbled across a Transformers Club
but there's nothing that Gregory and I
love more that a Michael Bay directed
transformers film we've seen all of them
in the theaters IMAX 3d there's a new
one this is the last night and we've got
a clip called a canopy let's do this
[ __ ] play it homeboy Tommy G
[Music]
love salvation children let's try out a
rumble a bit straighter
[Laughter]
[Music]
mom's boy Camaro
[Music]
gee I'm so glad transformers is becoming
stranger things now
yeah even even children can get sweaty
and dirtied up for Michael Bay movies
that's cool hey you know what [ __ ] it if
we're gonna do this again and we're
gonna spend another five and a half
hours watching
Optimus Prime do some [ __ ] in the world
that they don't want to be fighting here
um the FBI they Allspark cool let's
bring kids into this [ __ ] because I hope
at least you know the camera's not gonna
be like lusting over them the holds you
know only honestly I like a time talking
some [ __ ] some silliness but yeah
for kids doing the strangest thing [ __ ]
transformers let's do it males I find it
funny how Logan was like the egg
apocalypse day for mutants and it had
like kids is like yeah importing
characters and this is like the
apocalypse time for the Transformers
times of rebirth yeah exactly the future
right here whew they're the ones that
we're gonna have to become adults and
raise families in a time after this war
of their random robots or mother Sam
Witwicky zuv tomorrow
yeah showing up and getting their
parents high when they go off to college
it's gonna be amazing I mean that cliff
look like I tried to have actual meaning
to it though like Oh danger Robocop
monster monster that's a monster Johnny
Papaji going chin bumblebee rises I'm
here to help the children yeah yeah yeah
well you know I feel like anytime you
had children it's an opportunity because
like if you [ __ ] up a story about
children having to fight after galactic
robots you know like that's pretty hard
well this will get more families to go
watch it now there's kids in there oh
yeah dude bring your six-year-old your
five-year-old your three-year-old don't
we relate yeah they love bumblebee yeah
and they really care about
galactic relations and if there's
anything I know about children is that
they [ __ ] get amps they get jacked
whenever [ __ ] Sir Anthony Hopkins
sure I mean the amount of kids I've
talked to you about Westworld theories
alone it's insane it's off the chain so
like I think families are gonna flock to
this man it's gonna be great love
Michael Bay to make a family film I wish
Michael Bay would make a family film
like like it in the Arnold
Schwarzenegger style one like a jingle
all the way movie like that's the
Michael Bay I wanted out of this life
like PG but with all his extra [ __ ] and
you just like you ever see one of those
PG movies where there's like an
attractive female lead that you can tell
the camera that wants to grope but they
can like I want to see Michael Bay in
that situation just because you know I I
think that would be entertaining to
watch him cinematically squirm yeah it
could be like a family film one of the
characters to be Megan Fox if it has no
luck finding guys Fox is like is like
the cool aunt you know what it's gonna
be like a like a like a dan in real life
you know but oh yeah from Michael Bay
you know well subscribe to the real
region John's reasons to Jerry on
Instagram and Twitter he's a social
media manager of glove house and the
real rejects its food time in bed tough
times I'm gonna watch an episode of tea
more than working and then I'm gonna go
home and fall asleep watching old
episodes of like king of the hill